talk so if we could
um if we could begin i'd uh
appreciate it quit sending me emails
um never stop
never stop good luck welcome back tom
thank you okay okay
i will start with the german script i
believe
everybody is here and um
so here goes as chair of division two of
the house finance committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the coven 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12.
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this public meeting will be discussing
amendments to hb1 and hb2
note that there is no physical location
for members of the public
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting
however in accordance with emergency
order
i am confirming that all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules
and rsa 91-a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should email lba
underscore fiscal at leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting assisting
us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote let's
start the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
representative lynn i am glad you're
back
and i know that representative petrie is
really glad that you're back so if you
would
please yes thank you madam chair
uh representative bucco and welcome
welcome back sir
thank you sir i'm i'm present i'm at my
home in conway and there's no one else
in the house
uh representative heath uh good morning
um i'm representative mary heath and i'm
here
in my home in manchester new hampshire
and i'm all alone
representative mirner
i'm in lancaster home all alone
thank you uh i'm representative lynn i'm
here in uh
orlando florida and i'm in alone in the
room uh
at this time representative petry
representative petrie's in farmington
with just the dog today
representative murray kate murray is in
newcastle uh with just the dog
uh yes i'm in uh in kearsarge and my
husband
is in the uh in the house someplace
but kate i'm happy to learn that your
husband's not in the basement today
no he's outside droning oh that's just
like right and representative weiler
you're
you're i guess a guest for purposes of
this meeting anyway but welcome
thank you okay um
i uh we had discussed the
amendment that um representative
weiler had submitted
and we asked him for
additional information
because we didn't really have a clear
[Music]
understanding of what he was asking for
so representative wyler if you would
please tell us about your amendment and
why you think it's important
well thank you madam chair and my local
school board is
there's two towns represented and
the way they read the law and so there's
this
in effect i think two members from
kingston two members from newton
and one member at large and the way they
interpreted
the law if somebody resigned or died of
any of those members
that the board would replace
that member but it was their reading of
the law was if it was somebody from
kingston
then really it only came down to the
kingston person would have a hand in
selecting the
replacement but it said
the person that was the at-large member
whether they were elected in kingston or
in newton
were denied a say in who would
replace the absent number
and it didn't make sense especially if
that person the member at large was
elected in the same town
as the as the member that was absent
and even if they were from the next town
they were still uh elected in the town
that the person was absent from so they
they had roots they felt in both towns
and certainly in the town
that they came from and the board
decided no that wasn't the case
because you weren't as a member
as the member from kingston in fact but
and they they argued about that and it
wasn't clear in the law so they asked me
to try to change the law so it was clear
that the at-large member
if especially if they were from the same
town as as a
person being replaced then they should
have a vote in that or have a
have a hand in selecting that person i
agreed with
last year i submitted the bill it passed
through the education committee
the senate like so many other of our
efforts um
it either got i can't remember exactly
whether it got
tabled or just jumbled in a bill with 24
other
things many of which were not popular so
it didn't go anywhere
and i forgot about that i kind of lost
track of it once i passed it through the
house
and uh and the member that asked me to
put it in called up and said you know
that bill didn't go anywhere i said all
right i'll put it in again but by the
time they told me that
we'd already passed the filing period so
i was hopeful that since it's
deals with education and division two
deals with education that
i i could have it supported to put it in
hb2
because it is it is an important issue
for my town
and it was passed through the education
committee
previously and and they supported it
so i'm hopeful that you will put it in
hb2 thank you
happy to answer any questions are there
any questions that
anyone has uh representative murray
thank you very much madam chair and this
is by and large for my own education
um first a member at large it would be
my understanding that that person
isn't representing any particular
area or issue or any entity in a
committee
that's for me a definition of member at
large
so what does it matter if you're
replacing a member at large
where that member comes from as you know
shouldn't it be a if it's a member at
large shouldn't it continue to be a
member at large
and does this bill kind of hamstring
what the intent of member at large is
supposed to do
thanks thank you i think it does in
effect
because the issue that brought it to a
head was
not the member at large replacement but
one of the other replacements
in this instance i think it was somebody
in kingston being
had resigned or death excuse me or died
and they had to be replaced and so the
member at large
was elected in kingston and in newton
and
supposedly only the member that was
elected as the kingston member that was
remaining
would be the one that would choose the
replacement that didn't make sense to
the member at large
because she was also from kingston so
i felt she had a right to pick the
person or have a hand in it so
and i could agree with that and i could
see that you know if she was from
kingston and
knew the people in kingston that she
would be just as likely to
know who to put in that job as as the
one that was singularly
elected from kingston so that's what the
bill does and they
didn't even give it a thought to what
would happen it requires to be replaced
uh representative murray urban peace i
believe you were next
thank you thank you mr chair um just so
i understand
um in um a consolidated school district
um it's usually when they come together
to be an sau
uh they merge in the sau board
in uh yes it is the sau board you're
talking about i presume
so the sau board is weighted according
to
the populations of each town
and so what you are recommending
is that when one of those at large
members needs to be replaced
then in fact it will be
the whole body or just the single town
from which that individual came
i'm trying to remember how i don't know
i'm sorry i don't have it in front of me
but i think it's maybe the nomination
would come from
the people in the town that
had lost the member so if they could
continue
to vote on it but the nominations would
be from the people in the town
would there be there would be no vote
um and then the town
then keeps control of
their member and does not need to go out
for a vote with all three towns
i wouldn't think it would no but maybe
the total board would vote
but the nomination and and likely
would come from the people within the
town that lost the member
okay thank you yeah uh representative
heath
that person would only be appointed
until the next election
right okay and so that would
you know whatever whenever that was yeah
okay representative lynn you have a
question
oh did you want to follow up mary i did
i just wanted to
understand the process um so what this
would do is simply solidify the process
and there wouldn't be any questions
that's my hope yes okay thank you
representative yes
thank you madam chair um uh
representative while i i
i understand completely what you're
saying and it seems to me this makes a
lot of sense
uh the only question the only question
that i have
is i mean as you just as you just
pointed out
what in in the example that you use what
it seems not to cover the situation
where
the person that uh resigns or
you know if for some reason uh no longer
remember the board
is the at-large member and so i wonder
um how how would we how do
let's suppose that that happens now how
do how is that at large member
replaced i think the way that the way it
reads even if it's the at-large member
what town was the at-large member from
and
was remaining from that town would be
the ones that nominate
or appoint the successor okay i see what
you're saying i see what you're saying
all right whether
whichever town it was from
okay thank you thank you are there
are there any other questions that
okay uh mickey i don't have the
uh amendment number in front of me
uh it's zero seven eight two h
thank you uh could i have a motion
please
to accept this amendment
okay seeing none uh representative
the clerk will call the role thank you
uh thank you uh representative bucca yes
uh representative heath yes
representative murder yes
uh representative lin votes yes uh
representative petry
representative pg votes yes
representative murray
murray votes yes representative
representative umberger votes yes it's a
vote of seven to zero in the affirmative
on that chair okay thank you very much
um our next order of business is
a um report from
uh representative lynn on the
um supreme court decision
on education
so i will turn it over to representative
lin
i want to thank you all oh you're quite
welcome
thank you uh
so um i as i i i sent representative
umberger
uh an email uh yesterday and i think
uh i guess the the bottom line
i suppose that way to put this is that
uh it's a punt
the supreme court decision is sort of a
punt in that
um it didn't make a final decision it
sent it back
to the uh to the trial court
but i i guess you know reading
uh and and this this is obviously i
i'm not a member of the supreme court i
can't speak for the supreme court i can
only make some predictions and they may
or may not be correct
but i think one of the one of the
takeaways
from this is that to the extent
uh that those challenging
the um what the legislature had done
with the school funding
you know in recent years to the extent
that they had the belief
that um they were just going to be able
to say
um you know this is what um
this is the cost of education that the
education
establishment thinks is what is what is
needed
and that was kind of going to be the end
of it which is
sort of what the trial court did i think
the the
supreme court kind of you know threw
cold water on that that that's not gonna
that's not gonna be um the way this is
handled
and sent it back to the trial court and
i would i and i suspect i could be wrong
on this but i suspect
that this is there's going to be a
fairly lengthy
discovery process and then a
fairly lengthy trial on the merits where
where this kind of this issue will be
very
very hotly contested as to exactly what
does
um an adequate education cost what
factors are
uh go into uh
establishing an adequate education and i
think particularly
i thought particularly interesting is
there is
language in the court's decision that i
think
um
really raises the issue uh uh
not er at least it seems to me
not everything that it go that is a cost
of education is a cost for an adequate
education in other words there may be
that a school district spends money on
um and i don't mean to say in it i don't
mean to suggest that it's that
spending the money is inappropriate but
there may be many things that a school
district
spends money on that the court will
ultimately say okay
that's fine but that's not part of an
adequate education
um so that for example i i i think that
as i understand it the school districts
that were challenging this were saying
you know the cost
whereas the legislature in that basic
appropriation
before there's added for the free and uh
reduced lunch and
other costs uh um non-english speakers
that kind of thing
but in the basic um cost of of an
adequate education
it was around at the time i think 2019
around 3 500 or 3 600
and the school districts were saying oh
it's 16 or 17
000 uh per student um
i think that um
there's that's there's a great deal of
room in there
and the supreme court i think uh
it's not it's not going to i shouldn't
say made it clear
raised real real questions about whether
or not
a lot of the things that school
districts may
uh spend money on are really what is
required
for an adequate education so
you know my takeaway from this is i said
to representative umbergers i
i tend to think that if i were a
litigant
on the representing the state if i were
if i were a lawyer representing the
state i would feel
much better about the supreme court's
decision
than if i were a lawyer representing the
challenge
challenging school districts that's not
to say that there ultimately
the school districts won't win in some
fashion but
i do think that um the
people that were defending uh the
the uh the legislative the
defending the law um probably are
feeling
uh better about the decision than the
so that's kind of i'm happy to try to
answer any questions uh
if anybody has it uh representative
murray you have a question
yes thank you um the commission on
adequacy that finished its work just i
guess in the past several months or so
do you think that being such a new
report
impacted the court's decision to say you
know you need to go back and look at
this some more
and since that is out now and it wasn't
out when some of this was going on
do you think they will make either side
we'll make use of
the findings from that commission uh
going forward to try to figure out you
know answering the questions that you
just asked
no excellent question and i think you
know i don't um i don't remember the
court
referring to the newest
report and i think probably that's
because that
um i don't that may not have been issued
at the time the trial court made
its decision and so you know the way the
process works is the supreme court can
only consider what was before the trial
court
so if the trial court didn't have the
benefit of that then
the supreme court really really uh would
it would have been kind of improper for
it to
to consider it but on remand now you
know i
i think yes i'm sure that um
you know in in term in trying to
determine factually
what um what goes into an adequate
education
um i'm sure that the the the uh
both sides will probably you know make
reference to that and the court the
trial court i think will
will almost necessarily have to you know
at least deal with what
so any other any other questions i'm
yes uh thank you uh judge uh for taking
my question
uh are you familiar with the uh what
happened in new jersey i believe they
had a claremont decision
uh their academic achievement has uh not
improved a bit
and they're spending in the abbott
districts there which are the poor
districts are spending
over forty four thousand dollars per
student
i'm not i i sort of am generally
familiar that there
are you know there are a number what you
should bear in mind
is this uh way back in 1973
the u.s supreme court rejected
the kind of under the federal
constitution the kind of claim that was
made in the claremont case
uh basically saying that you know there
um
there is no constitutional right to
uh um an adequate quote-unquote uh
education or equal funding of education
that's just not something that the
federal constitution grants in the wake
of that a number of states
new jersey kentucky and i think you know
i'm not sure the number now but quite a
number have said that their state
constitution provides
um this protection um
[Music]
i the the problem this is now this is me
speak you know
people may have i understand that people
have a much people may have a much
different take on this than i do but
this is me speaking i
uh candidly think that it
that this is not a very smart move for
states to adopt this because what it
involves in the end is
um you know stop and think about this
the court instead of
instead of us in the legislature
deciding how much money to appropriate
to education
and i've been don't get me wrong i
personally am
very much favor the idea that poorer
school districts ought to get
aid from the state i don't have any
problem with that at all
but the idea that um
it shouldn't be the legislature that
decides that issue
but instead the court um
i i'm i think that's i'm very
uncomfortable with that because i think
what it really means is
let's you know let's it essentially
means that you've got the court
substituting its judgment for the
legislature on what
on how much money is is appropriate to
be spent on education
and more importantly what the trade-offs
are
if the if education were the only thing
we were spending money on
it might be one thing but there's you
know a whole bunch of
different things that we have to spend
money on and so the problem i see and i
think
the case the states that have adopted
this
their whose courts have adopted this the
problem is it's kind of never-ending
so you know let's assume that the
plaintiffs are right and that you know
uh the amount of money that's being
spent spent for an adequate education
now the court says
that's not enough okay so now we
appropriate
more money um so five years from now or
three years from now or
ten years from now the somebody will say
and
and this is i what i think is the real
problem
if this by saying that this is a
constitutional right it really means
that anybody
you know it could be it it here it was a
several school districts
but it could be anybody that can say oh
wait a minute i don't think the state's
spending enough money i'm bringing a
lawsuit
and
ultimately the court as opposed to the
legislature will decide how much money
should be spent
that that um
i i i'm i'm very troubled by by
that idea so but that's that's my you
know that's my personal take on this
and i think that the the spending
i mean i think that that the new jersey
case and others
indicate that the spending issue is not
um is not uh
in any way kind of closely related to
educational performance
i think that's uh at least that's my
take on
but anyway that's the you know many of
you may i'm sure may disagree with that
but that's
kind of my take uh representative heath
you have a question
oh thank you ma'am chair this is like an
ongoing issue that has caused angst for
many many years
um i agree that that the courts
won't tell us what to do
but the courts will advise
the body the general court then in fact
they need to come up with a better way
to meet the needs of children in the co
in our our national in our federal
constitution
they left education to
the states to decide how to determine
um how to address that issue and so i
i do think that we bear responsibility
the other issue that really being on the
school funding commission
this this past year really pointed to
the deep discrepancies in the level
to which different communities
can afford to really address
the needs of education in their
communities you know
we just saw the huge difference in in
the
uh property tax burden that different
towns
carry and um i think that's something
that in all of this
and again it goes back to the report
from the commission i think it's
incredibly important that somewhere
along the line
and i think we did that um at some point
when we
um provided funding in one of our
previous bills
and i just i just think it's a
consideration that we have to address
because i think ultimately economically
for our state
the product of the children that we
produce
in all our communities results in
higher qualified future employers and
employees
um thank you judge i really appreciate
your comments
um because it just it brings home so
many of the issues we've we've
really talked about for so long and and
muddled with and it's been very
difficult
in terms of massachusetts and new jersey
i'd like to talk to both of those just
quickly
both of those states have undergone
really
total school reform and and with that
reform
have seen significant improvements in
their students achievement
as we know massachusetts is listed
number one on the nape
and new jersey which was drastically
lower
has come up to one of the um top states
so there has been improvement
based on the addition of funding
provided so um i
i thank you judge again and i will be
quiet thank you
thank you i hope
folks will indulge me and allow
representative wyler
to ask a question representative wyler
thank you ma'am sharon thank you it just
seems like this
is almost an annual thing i know you've
dealt with it
with supreme court and lower lower
courts and
it's it never ends and i think one of
the reasons the union always is trying
to kill the charter schools as they
serve as a
prime example that an adequate education
can be done for seven
thousand but another issue that i've
seen several members
online tossing around is the unfunded
mandate
unfunded mandates and i remember an
earlier
um i don't know if it was a supreme
court or a circuit court
with the decision you know if so we're
spending about 40 percent of the of the
cost of
30 or 40 percent of the cost is from the
state
and every time the state decides there's
going to be some addition
to what's required like a civics program
or something
then they come back and they sue and
call it an unfunded mandate and my
reelection
uh my remembrance is that the court said
as long as you're getting money you
can't say it's unfunded
it doesn't matter they you know they
don't tell you exactly how to spend the
money but
they're giving you money they give you a
new mandate
you've gotten money it's not unfunded
you think that's still the feeling
thank you well i i
i say i i actually had occasion i was
the author of the decision
that said um you know it was okay for
the state
not to fund the municipal retirement
uh system and that was i think it was a
four to one decision i believe justice
convoy
dissented in that but i think it was
either a four to one or three to one
decision
um i appreciate it i'm the one that made
the change
but it um one of the i one of the
problems
i think that we you know that we re that
was the basis of the decision not the
total basis but in part was
that it's um
[Music]
the the things like
uh like the like the retirement fund and
that i i suppose it would have
implications here
you know for in the in the
hypothetically you pose because if the
state says okay you have to do
you know you have to now teach x
um presumably that's gonna
that's gonna mean some funding for
personnel and yet
the state has no control over
personnel and that was one of the big
things that you know
the the the city of manchester or for
you know from
from the biggest city to the smallest
town they get to make their own
decisions on how much how many
how much how many how many employees
they have
how much their employees are paid and
yet
if they could if the if the
you know non-funded mandate provision
meant that the legislature
um was kind of stuck with that it would
really interfe
it would really interfere basically with
the legislature's ability to appropriate
money and to decide how much
how much funding goes to uh to
to various things so i think you're
right that i think we basically did say
in that case that if there's been
you know if there's been um
some uh if there's been
some funding by localities for
for for you know sort of general
categories of things like employees
than the state um then the fact that the
state changes its contribution is not
uh doesn't result in an unfunded mandate
as i say that's not the only factor
there are a number of other factors that
went into it but that's certainly one of
them
okay thank you very much representative
lynn
um thank you from uh
speaking to us from your experience um
i think it's uh insightful
and i know that we will all be waiting
for
whatever the trial court decides to
uh move forward with and uh i'm not sure
that
you know we'll have a decision on that
during this
legislative session if in fact they do
what they've been directed to do
so anyhow it'll be fun and uh
it may be um you know two years before
we
come up with any any decision on that
so thank you again and
yes okay um
we have uh an amendment
is that the next thing we want to do uh
at this point we have three amendments
um okay to be considered and one of the
three amendments would
require a reconsideration of an
amendment with that we previously
approved so
we can take these three up in any order
that works for you and um
if it's helpful to walk through a screen
share we can do that
um you tell us what you want to do yeah
let's do the
amendment on the
44 million sure so this would be
amendment uh 2021-1019h
and i think this was sent out to
and this is an amendment that uh that
would require
reconsideration of amendment zero nine
eight nine
h that we had previously adopted and the
reason for that is
uh both amendments ultimately result in
a
transfer from the education trust fund
to the general fund
the amendment one zero one nine h takes
into consideration
previous actions and updates that
transfer amount required we would not
wanna
pass both so we would wanna supersede
zero nine eight nine with this should
the division adopt it
okay um you want to uh
walk us through what what this is uh
suggesting
sure so andrea has the amendment shared
on the screen right now so
um as of all the committee's action
to this point um there is
about 40 just over 41 million dollars
remaining in the education trust fund
based on the revised house ways and
means revenues
so what this amendment would do is
essentially
appropriate some general fund dollars
for the department of transportation
this is the section one that you see
lines
uh one through eleven of that nineteen
million dollars
four million dollars would be for
highway block grant
uh under apportionment a highway block
grants to cities and towns
five million dollars would be a transfer
to the highway and bridge betterment
fund that dot uh runs
six million dollars would be for dot to
uh acquire fleet vehicles
and equipment and four million dollars
would be appropriated for winter
maintenance
i can continue if unless there's any
questions well go ahead we'll ask the
questions
okay am i am i silent no no i will ask
yeah we'll ask the questions at the end
okay
uh section two of this bill is relative
to school building aid
and that starts on line 12 of this
amendment rather
so in total in total there's um
a 17 million dollars 17.3
in the first year and 10.6 in the second
year
and if we jump down to lines 17 through
24 you will see
what the purpose is so of that amount
eight million dollars in fiscal 22
would go towards accelerating some of
those tail payments so
this is essentially an effort to pay
down some of that outstanding obligation
that the state has up through i think
fiscal
2042 so
districts that have projects on their
routine payment schedule under this
would receive
an expedited portion prorated across all
the projects by the department in the
amount of eight million dollars total
and then in uh sub paragraph b on line
there's 9 million 278 000 in fiscal 20
uh two and 10 million 558 000 of fiscal
23 for new school building aid projects
these appropriations would be from the
education trust fund
as you know the school building aid
program now we do budget that
sub paragraph or paragraph roman 3 on
line 25
as you all know there is a cap
on school building eight expenditures of
50 million dollars per year
with this new infusion of dollars into
these payments
i think because of timing it's probably
probable doe
could be up against that cap so what
this does is it suspends that provision
just for the biennium to allow
uh doe to be able to make payments
without being uh non-compliant with that
law
the net of all these actions and the
actions previously taken to approve some
of the uh
general fund appropriations from from
yesterday
section 3 on line 28 is the education
trust fund
transfer to the general fund to cover
all the appropriations
from before as well as essentially the
dot portion of the appropriations today
so the amendment we had approved before
zero nine eight nine h had a transfer of
12 million in the first year and 10.7 in
the second year
this would be 27.5 in the first year and
okay are there any
i will add the net impact of all this
for the education trust fund is
uh it would essentially balance to zero
it would be balanced
to the penny there'd be no additional
surplus in the education
trust fund or deficit at the end of
fiscal 23
representative heath oh thank you madam
chair
you know i have to say all the things
that relate to building aid
and the cap i i can agree with all that
and i i just love to see more money
going into building it
what bothers me is taking money from the
education trust
um and sending it to the department of
transportation
for all things that i would love to see
added by the way
so i'm struggling a lot with this
because yes indeed d.o.t needs help
um really desperately but i just am
uncomfortable it's a different
utilization of the other dollars because
in fact
they're going for an educational purpose
and when we took money
um out of the the amendment and we sent
it to
the university system we took we
transferred money from the trust to the
um
general fund uh we sent it to the
university
and to the community colleges to level
fund them we also paid for
running start which is near and dear to
both of our hearts
but my big big concern is taking money
out of the education trust and sending
it to the department of transportation
so can you somebody talk to me
about that and and make me feel better
about that change because it does
disturb me greatly because
i'm afraid that it's going to set a
precedent that we don't want to do
okay if i can i think we all realize
the highway fund is in big time trouble
okay and the
items that are in this particular bill
number one affect the city's accounts
you all know
that we had to reduce
the highway block grant because
of money
not available in in the from the gas tax
also i believe commissioner
shaheen said that
the betterment would be
reduced because of the lack of
the gas tax and
we have talked about not having
money for the equipment and
um so i understand where you're coming
from
representative heath but
i also feel that
although this money is all in the
education trust fund
that the needs of the department of
um yeah the needs of the highway fund
are such that it only makes sense
to provide that money um
for for the needs of the state
and um i i know i understand where
you're coming from
uh but i also think that um
19 million i think it was the figure
from
for d.o.t that
we have in many ways
with the other what what i've proposed
with the other funding
have significantly helped the
um the education of our you know the
education
side of it with the um school building
aid
i know that that is a a huge
issue and i also felt that by paying
down
the money that doe owes
would allow us in the next biennium
you know not this year but in the next
biennium
to have um extra dollars
to provide to building aid
and i know that i know that there's
a lot of conflict between building aid
okay and transportation
so if we simply put this
um 19 million
into building aid in addition to
the um money that we have
that has been appropriated through this
i think that overall for the state
that when we are looking at um
the best use of the dollars at this time
okay i may not feel that way
in two years but at this time
i feel that it is just so important
that we are able to
help out the highway fund
and continue to provide the things that
are are so necessary not only for the
towns
but also for the state and i know we had
talked
yesterday about um
trying to move some money for equipment
over to the um the highway fund
uh out of the education trust fund so
it's not
it's not a new concept i'll put it that
way so
that's kind of where where i'm coming
from
and why i made these recommendations
um i just i i am just
so concerned about the highway fund
i really really am and that this was
the only way that i knew of to
help bolster the uh the highway fund
so that's my that's my pitch
thank you man you're welcome
representative murray
uh thank you yeah just a couple things
first i need to i guess
preemptively apologize to mickey because
i wasn't able to find the the
amendments and the packet that he sent
because it's it's this very faint blue
ink that says
down or show all amendments so it always
takes me forever to find that one i did
find them
so thank you for sending that out um a
concern i have is that this does not
solve the problem of the highway fund
going forward
um and so i
totally agree that transportation needs
help that you know and everything that
you've said
they need all that money but i just you
know have to
point out that this is not the solution
to the highway fund
um and i wanted to ask um if anyone can
speak to and maybe mickey has
some idea of this going forward are
there any unintended consequences
that we that could be foreseen otherwise
then they wouldn't be unintended
um but in having the education trust
fund
go to zero and the last thing i was
concerned i just
i would and i know we don't know this um
i am hopeful and
probably fairly optimistic that there
will be federal money that will help the
transportation
um and now you're shaking your head no
is that not do we not
oh i was hoping that there may be
federal funds i'll let you speak to that
but those are my concerns about this but
i
am always all for helping out
transportation as much as we possibly
can
i do have a little anxiety about the
go ahead mickey say as far as far as the
education
trust funds uh position at the end of a
year
or biennium there is a law
that allows for um the general fund to
kick in
any deficit the education trust fund may
be in to finish a year
so as far as making adequacy payments
there's an open warranton statute for
that
and the general fund would make an
automatic transfer to the education
trust fund should it
run a deficit um those who have been
around for a while
recall for many years we had tens of
millions if not hundreds of millions of
dollars in some years of a deficit in
the education trust fund requiring a
general fund
support at the end of the year to bring
it back to a zero so um
it's certainly not uncommon to have a
budget plan
with an education trust fund balance to
be close to zero or in a lot of cases
uh matt you wanted to speak
hello yep you're there excellent thank
you madam chairwoman uh nikki
accurately covered most of what i wanted
to say the only thing i'll add is
on the federal money side there is a
very small portion out of the american
rescue plan that
may be eligible for revenue replacement
we're still waiting on guidance from the
u.s treasury to identify exactly how
we might be able to deploy those dollars
for transportation
but to the extent that we can at all it
is a very small sliver
of that total package so i don't have an
estimate just yet because again we're
still waiting on guidance but
that would be the only set of flexible
money in the new federal bill
that could even be considered for this
purpose
yeah i also understand from what uh
commissioner sheehan said
that d.o.t itself
is not expecting any
um dollars to take care of
the uh issues that i
have covered in this uh particular
amendment
i i would say that's definitely accurate
um
i will say of course the feds did give
us 41 million dollars that we've already
budgeted
uh in revenue replacement as part of the
governor's budget
in addition to that 8.1 million dollar
lapsed from a previous house bill
hb 1817 um
so that's all i would say is that we
have seen some some support we've
already kicked in
some general fund support to balance the
highway fund
um but we have used almost all of the
resources at our disposal
okay did that answer your question
representative murray
yes thank you very much okay
are there other questions that we have
okay uh seeing none
uh could i have a motion on amendment
1019h please
second thank you
um is there are is there any further
discussion
okay uh representative oh i'm sorry
representative heath you have a question
i do
because i'm really i have to say i'm
really really struggling with this
um i like everything we're doing
um but that said
i really don't like taking money out of
the trust to send to transportation
um
[Music]
is there any money available from
someplace
else that could go to d.o.t
no if i could just um clarify
something we've got we have another
amendment after this one zero one eight
h which actually has a transfer going
the other way
so this amendment is going to transfer
money from the education trust fund and
spend it as general fund
that next amendment is going to transfer
general funds into
the education trust fund and spend it as
education trust fund
after these two amendments are brought
up it can be the committee's
decision and give me the authority to
essentially blend those two transfers
together net them together
because at the end of the day here these
two amendments are actually sending
general fund money into the education
trust fund
and we could and then that way the
transfer from education trust them
wouldn't be
associated with some of these spending
items i know that's kind of confusing
we're talking across two documents but
um
that is essentially what's happening if
if both of these amendments here today
one zero one eight and one zero one nine
okay does that answer your question mary
representative heath yes yes ma'am chia
thank you
um i'm still in a muddle to be honest
though um
i just don't know what to do because
this is a conundrum of of
i'd like to see these things take place
but i'm just not sure about the
education trust
so actually um
based on that um probably
we will go along with um this amendment
um but we'll continue to have a another
conversation after this
thank you madam chair thank you
okay representative are there any other
questions comments
representative lin would you call the
role please
yes uh thank you madam chair uh
representative
petrie petry ots uh representative bucco
yes uh representative heath
thank you representative uh
representative berna yes
representative lynn votes yes uh
representative murray
murray votes yes and uh representative
umber
representative berger votes yes it's a
vote of seven
uh to zero in the affirmative madam
chair
thank you very much so i i maybe should
have clarified at the beginning of that
motion
um if you wanted to do it all together
but since we didn't i would ask that you
reconsider
amendment 0989 h adopted yesterday
as that this amendment you just adopted
would
essentially overwrite that so i just
want to make it clear the committee's
okay so we need to uh
i mean just as long as it's clear that
you're not going to adopt ultimately
zero nine eight nine h
you adopted it you want to reconsider
that you won't know i guess yeah so i
guess that's right
okay representative peace uh madam chair
could
ricky just walk through the amendment
that we're going to
um override um
because i just want to make sure i'm i'm
fully understanding what i'm i'm voting
for
uh yes mary we all have that problem
can i ask one oh oh
there we go okay so through
through the air just hang on just a
second uh representative
please uh raise your hand
on the uh on your computer
okay so that we can uh keep ourselves
straight so representative murray or
i'm sorry was it representative heath is
that correct
you had a question um
you you wanted um questions being
addressed right now by mickey
to exactly what this amendment does
versus
the amendment that we just did so what
are we undoing
so this if you recall the amendment we
just adopted
had um a transfer an education trust
fund transfer to
the general fund for the appropriations
we had already done that to pay for
previously adopted items that the
committee did
so we don't want two transfers that
transfer amount that you just approved
was net of everything we already did so
i already trued it up to what we need
and we this previous one is no longer
necessary
a question just quick question it
doesn't undo anything we did for the
community college the university system
none of that it's simply okay thank you
representative bucco you have a question
uh
yes thank you am i on me okay yes you
are um
could i ask that uh mickey to
resend those amendments because i don't
remember seeing them and i
i may have deleted them with the other
200 emails that i was
trying to get through i i can certainly
send that to
to you or um i don't know if
representative buco you've explored the
division two web page every amendment is
right on there too
listed by the number so maybe i'll send
you the link and then that way you're
here to find everything
okay does that take care of your
question tom
yes that's fine thank you okay
all right so um
amendment 0989h
second thank you can i you know
can i'm i'm sorry can i just ask the
question i want to make sure that what
we're doing is correct if we
if if the idea would be that we would
vote not that we would vote no
and not consider amendm
amendment 0 9
8 9. then doesn't that mean that that
that we're leaving that amendment in
place shouldn't
shouldn't we be voting yes yeah i think
technically you would yes to reconsider
it and then just ultimately not
adopt it again so i think i mean if you
don't have to follow
parliamentary procedures here if you
just want to make a clear motion that
you're
deleting section zero nine eight nine
from your recommended
amendments that works for me i just
needed to be clear that the idea was
that last amendment replaces the old one
that we adopted
and i think everyone's on the same page
with that with what's going on here i
hope
um okay
so why don't we why don't we try
what mickey said tell them in my motion
okay and that that works for me that
works
okay so uh
represent lynn would you please call the
roll yes thank you uh
representative petrie get your votes yes
representative bucca uh yes
representative heath uh heath beauchess
uh representative lin votes yes uh
representative murray
murray votes yes and representative
humber
uh votes yes thank you it's a 7-0 vote
in the affirmative
thank you very much uh representative
bucco
could you uh figure out how to drop your
hand
uh yeah right oh it's gone now
uh yeah i know you've been gone for two
weeks so uh
it's all new it's all new it's like
uh going back to uh january
mickey we have two more amendments is
that correct
we do yes okay
um
uh okay that's the wrong one
see if i can summarize what
uh because it's the result what's
happening is is that we're spending the
same money in different ways
is that correct mickey between these two
amendments
yeah uh close uh so the the one
amendment relative to swept is around
100 million dollars
the um the other amendment relative to
education funding is
closer to just over 140 million dollars
than that
impact of of that one so um but that's
that's they're both um
what essentially the way that they're
written to have a general fund impact
as the education trust fund to all the
decisions that we've made to this point
the education trust fund is at a right
at zero so
um anything you would these two
amendments would essentially affect
general
okay so uh
representative heath would you um
talk to us about your amendment thank
you madam chair
um so madam chair what i understand your
amendment is going to do
is it's going to transfer um into the
trust
um 100 million dollars and
that money would be used to indeed
um put
[Music]
toward reducing the
overall statewide property tax on
education
the amendment that i am proposing
and and i have a number of questions
that would go with that but let me let
me talk to my amendment my amendment
as it would be h basically what's in hb
623 and what 623
does at a critically important time
in our our our situation that we're in
right now
it returns funding levels to that
which school districts received in
the 2021 second year of the biennium
and it um includes
disparity aid and some of the targeted
aid
that we sent to school districts and um
i really think that this is critically
important to our school districts
because the reduction in in prop up to
statewide property taxes
you know what does this mean for a
community like berlin
and cutting swept simply ultimately
really puts a further burden on all the
other towns that don't
retain their their swept funds like some
of the others and that difference has to
be made up
ultimately so while i i totally agree
with the concept
of reducing statewide property taxes
um i can't i i can't in good heart
um knowing that there is this much money
available
deny the school districts that so
desperately they need
these funds so what i'm proposing and
you have um uh jeff mcclinch put
together
a funding chart and you will see with
623 on that chart that you received this
morning from mickey
the amount of money utilizing 623 that
each school district across our state
would receive
if we were to adopt 623 and and i think
this is something
that um we saw in in the report
from the the state of the school funding
commission
the importance of really sending money
to those districts that need it so
desperately
why we are as a state spending enormous
amounts of money
on education those school districts
that can least afford it are struggling
the most with their property taxes
so i think in what you're trying to do
madam chair
is you're trying to overall reduce
statewide property taxes
when in fact if we were to adopt 623
i think it would be a win-win situation
for everybody
we would in fact be providing greater
dollars to those school districts most
in need
and at the same time the other
communities would also be receiving
funds and we would do nothing
to um compromise their additional swept
money that most
many of those communities um that are so
well off
uh continue to keep so with that madam
chair i put forward the amendment that
that um
we have this morning and that amendment
is number
zero seven two one h and i thank you for
consideration
and i hope the committee as a whole will
consider this what it can do
for our entire state and every single
school district across our state
considering what everyone has gone
through with the pandemic
the numbers um what this also will do
will
it will increase school district
enrollment numbers free and reduced as
well as numbers
that will um take it back to what the
numbers were
previously so we see a lot of things
happening
in this amendment as a result um
of us my asking you to consider this
so i thank you madam chair
thank you representative heath are there
okay uh representative yes can i just
can i just ask a question
am i understanding correctly
that the read that the reason
that a school district in
without this amendment that the reason
that a school district
might not receive an amount that was the
equivalent
of what it received in the um
in the prior year is that there's been
a reduction in the number of students
in the school district is that is that
correct yes right and
and so if i'm
if and am i correct that that there may
be a whole bunch of reasons for the
reduction
uh uh presumably to the extent that the
reason was
um uh has something to do with covid
by the time that this uh budget
is uh in effect that
should i would think largely be over
and to the extent that so that those
students would return
unless those students have decided based
upon
the the the public schools
the manner in which the public schools
have dealt with covet that they're no
longer satisfied with the public schools
that have decided to go
and have decided to go to private
schools
hello
okay i'm sorry i had a call and i need
to answer it
um i think the answer to
all of your questions uh represent lynn
oh i'm not sure i didn't need to
interrupt i apologize no no that's fine
within the uh formula right now
we have the um stabilization
grant which um
did you get it which normally again yeah
the providing dollars
for student enrollment
in the past i think that's how
i can explain that it may not be
somebody may have a better explanation
than that but
there are dollars in there for that
quote-unquote
stabilization um requirement
and uh and that helps in many cases
uh towns like berlin
that lost um
lost a lot of students when they
lost the paper mill and any number of
other things and so
that was why the stabilization grant was
there
i'm sorry representative heath thank you
ma'am chair if i just i could
make a couple of comments yeah excuse me
just second
mickey could you take this amendment off
this here this is representative heath's
amendment okay i
that's what i was looking for excuse me
thank you
go ahead representative heath i i
apologize for
not being able to read thank you i just
wanted to talk to um
um representative lynn's comments and
also um just to talk a little bit about
what was done
in the lost biennium in terms of funding
for school districts
i think due to the covid pandemic and
the um urgency for for children to stay
at home
yes in fact a lot of children did not
appear
on the rolls um however we're starting
to see
the children come back in fact a lot of
children did go
to non-public schools they went to
private schools because many private
schools did stay
open but at the same time school
districts
are right now as we speak being forced
to do their individual school district
budgets
based on numbers that are significant
lower low much lower than the previous
years
so it's what we're seeing and
actually sb 135 which
representative hennessey brought forward
begins to address that but it does not
include
in her in her uh bill um
the elements that that we see
in the funding year of 2021
the disparity date and some of the
targeted aid which we believe at this
point is
is the most critical need across our
state for school funding
so with that i just really want to
impress
and again i urge you to look at the
printout
or look at the numbers for your school
district particularly
that mickey did send out that was put
together
by um uh representative uh
not reverend uh by jeff mc lynch um from
his
organization i also want to say that
this morning in house ed
um they are hearing sb 135
um and so i think that this is very much
in the conversation to bring those
enrollment numbers
up um and to in fact make school
districts
harmless from the just
myriad of issues that covet covet has
had
on school districts in relation to
personnel in relation to
technology needs and i get it i agree
wholeheartedly
that there are federal dollars large
federal dollars coming into
school districts but that said that does
not mitigate the issue
of the conversation going on right now
in every school district
um about the increase in or d
significantly decrease enrollments and
the amount of funding
that needs to school districts need to
know
what the impact on their property taxes
will be
and based on where we are in time right
this minute
school districts are struggling as will
be
taxpayers with the results of that
money and i do not believe that
the proposal that's going to be coming
forward with
100 million dollars to reduce the
statewide property taxes
will ameliorate the really impact of
what we have
currently the current situation
across our state with school districts
and their budgets and having to deal
with ultimately
is is kind of a crisis immediately
so i thank you madam chair and i thank
you representative lynn
can't hear you
am i no it's me the
the cost of your bill is
roughly 44 million dollars more
than 100 million
so how are you recommending
i i know there's nothing in here how
how are you recommending that
be reduced to the hundred million or are
you suggesting
that we put the whole 144 million
in thank you madam chair
that also was part of my reluctance on
voting yes
on the um amendment that we just had
because basically
that would have funded the increase to
623 that i was hoping to do
and and really make school districts
whole and and
bring back that level of funding to the
level that we provided
for school districts in 21 so
um again
i i don't know exactly where the
additional funding would come from
but i believe revenues are coming in
stronger than we had anticipated
and there are a number of possible
opportunities that may present
themselves so this money will come in
um so with that said i would um
i would end my testimony there thank you
madam chair
okay that's all right uh representative
murray
thank you very much madam chair um i've
been sitting here and i mean both
issues are extremely important and so
what i'm thinking in my head
is trying to suss out um you know
basically
where's the greater good uh they're both
good what
where's the balance in terms of um how
this will have
you know where where would the better
effect be and i lean
towards um representative heath's
amendment because of how it addresses
the specific issue
in the school and as schools are made
whole
then that provides relief to all the
communities as well with regards to
swept
so i guess just you know i'm looking at
in terms of trying to figure
out the greater good the best way to go
and i
think i right this point i have to
support uh representative heath's
okay uh are there any other comments
okay um the concern that i have
with this amendment and you have
identified it is that
in the last budget
you increased the amount of money
to school districts and so
in their adequate education
and so what happens is
that we end up in the same situation
in the next biennium that if we provide
additional dollars in adequacy at this
time
we will then have to go we will we will
hear
the same thing coming back 4
even though in your hb2
last year you indicated that this was
even if we identify this
as one-time money the expectation
is going to be that it will be there
going forward and
i'm not sure that
we should be spending one one-time
money to set ourselves up
for the same argument
every two years and that's that's one of
the reasons
why i brought in the amendment
to lower sweat because that
affects every every single
person that pays taxes
rather than adding
an expectation to the school districts
that we may or may not be able
to uh fund in the future and that's
that's the thing that um
you know we in 21 21 and 22
we had extra money we put it into
the into the system and now they expect
it
and that's where that's where my problem
is
so i am not in favor of
increasing expectations
of the school districts
uh over over time if
we can you know
if if uh if the revenue comes in
and we're
you know we're in a in a position in the
next budget
to bring 623 forward
or whatever else because we've got
several
study committees going on right now
on or they will be going on i know the
one
was completed but i believe there's
legislation out there to
create another study committee so okay
that's i so i i cannot support this
uh representative heath and i'm very
sorry about that but
uh representative murray did you have
some comments
um just a quick question because if it's
a hundred thousand dollars
um and being new i'm not always sure
could we prorate that hundred thousand
dollars to the school districts
you know as it's part of the 623 they
can't get all the amount we don't have
that
but can we prorate it so that the school
uh mickey do you want to answer that
question
uh we don't have an amendment that does
anything like that i mean we could
certainly craft
you know work on a way to infuse 100
million dollars even or pick a number
into the education funding formula um
that's not something we've
we've done to this point or have
anything prepared but just like any
other uh
idea you know certainly we could we
could work on something and
representative heath well thank you
madam chair
um i just want to go to your proposal
and just my big concern is cutting swept
simply
shifts further the burden into local
property taxes
where where towns and communities least
can afford it um i have to say that that
representatives
um murray's idea is one
that certainly has um a good
option and and um we could think about
what an amendment would look like
that would in fact increase the adequacy
amount for all school districts but also
um
reducing somewhat the um disparity aid
and the um uh the other um
funding the targeted funding that we put
out so we would just
proportion it out and i would ask
that maybe we have time to
um step back and put an amendment like
that together
so that in fact we would move we would
have time
to look at that as a whole with the
amount that with that hundred million
dollar amount
because quite frankly i don't i think
the
100 million going into swept
doesn't mitigate the issues it doesn't
talk to the enrollment issues it doesn't
talk to so many
of the the crisis issues that our school
districts are facing right now
so i wish that we could compromise
together
utilizing the funding that's available
and look at a better amendment that we
could come forward with
that would be a win-win for our school
districts across the state
hampshire
okay seeing none um
let me get my brain together um we have
we have two competing ideas
about what to do with this money
and i would
suggest that we vote on this
and then if this passes
we can uh bring in an amendment
and reconsider this okay
and um that way
you know we can do that
tomorrow or i guess or later today i
don't know if that can
that amendment can be uh completed
today or not but uh
go ahead represent a piece um madam
chair in light of what you just said
i would like to bring forward um
amendment number zero
seven two one h and i would look for a
second
so
okay uh mickey this is the 144 million
dollar
amendment
uh one yeah 141 is the number that i
have above the governor's
recommended budget levels for uh for
this amendment
okay so uh representative murray
sorry representative heath are you
withdrawing
zero seven two one h
and replacing here i would like to move
forward on this amendment
um knowing that we um
will go forward with working to
build another amendment utilizing the
100 million dollars that we have
available
okay thank you representative murray
um might it be possible to have that
vicky is that too much to ask
so i would just need to be clear on what
we're looking for for an amendment are
you looking for just a straight
proration of
uh the amendment so
essentially total education grants to
each municipality shall not be less but
then apply some sort of a
100 million dollar statewide cap that
doe would apply
pro rata across all town like i just
need some
direction as far as where to go with
with how you're
how you conceptualize capping it at 100
million
that was my initial idea what you just
expressed
i am open to suggestions if there is a
representative heath madam chair yes
thank you
um i would like to go ahead um with the
understanding
that that we're going to go forward with
another amendment because what 623 does
is it changes it does a lot of things
with the enrollment numbers
free reduced lunch for those numbers
it seems like a little simple amendment
but a lot happens in it
so if we could accept this amendment
with the understanding
that we'll come back to take the
elements of 623
um and and mickey knows this well um and
then created amendment will
um amend this amendment and come back
with the second amendment that stays
within the hundred million dollars
but in fact makes the school all school
districts
whole um based on um
the elements of 623
which is which is not whole but an
increase
yes okay i mean it's it's not a question
of whole
we can't say that it's a question of uh
of 144 million dollar increase
so okay uh who else has their hand up
i'm sorry
well i i seconded um
this is on zero seven two one
uh yes okay thank you
yes thank you madam chair uh it
uh i know uh when i go to the store i
make sure i get enough money in my
wallet
and i think we should wait and see what
uh
we have for revenue at the end of april
we'll probably have a better idea
and 135 sb 135 is coming our way so
we can uh we can add more money we could
possibly add
you know what we you know the same
amount as we did in the
previous year so i think that uh this is
going uh
you know you can't you can't spend if
you don't have it
okay
all right let me just oh i'm sorry i've
got somebody's hand up
thank you madam chair um i i would
consider
withdrawing this amendment if we
would be able to wait um for
us to work with um mickey to come up
with a new amendment
utilizing the amount of money that we
have available the 100 million dollars
that we do have available right now
okay the only problem we have with that
mary
uh represents sorry representative heath
is that we have another amendment to
vote on today
and so from from my perspective
um we we can vote on the amendment
these two amendments and if they pass
then they pass and the and if
if there needs to be amendments made
if they pass and there needs to be
amendments made
then i think i can i would agree that
we could get the amendment come back and
do whatever needed to be done
the madam chair i i will maintain my
amendment as it stands thank you very
much
okay thank you so uh
it's totally up to you representative we
we haven't really reviewed um
one zero one eight yet we've talked
about it but we i don't know if the
committee wanted to actually see the
amendment and
just understand what's going on um i
feel like we're we're deep into the
conversation with zero seven two one
right now and we do have a motion
on zero seven two one h so you may wanna
do that one first
representative lynn would you please
call the role
on 07218
yes thank you representative petry
representative petrie reluctantly votes
no
representative bucca yes
uh representative heath heath votes yes
representative mirner representative
myrna votes no
representative lynn votes no
i think i got my toggles backwards
representative murray votes yes and
representative
representative umberger votes no
all right madam chair it's a vote of
four to three um
okay
so we are now back to
defeated so uh
one zero one eight if we could bring
that up
please
i think andrea has that up there for us
so just so everyone understands we we
discussed this amendment as to what's
going on but
for fiscal year 23 state fiscal year
collections for the statewide education
property tax
this amendment would require that the
dra
set the tax rate at an amount to
raise 263 million dollars versus 300
million dollars which is per the
statutory level essentially what this
would do is result in 100 million
dollars less
in swept revenue statewide education
property tax revenue
to the education trust fund in fiscal 23
and then if you look down to section 2
of the bill on line 8
there is a 100 million dollar
appropriation from the general fund to
the education trust fund essentially
netting
uh to zero between these two actions as
far as impact on the education trust
okay are there any questions on this
representative heath chair i just want
to reiterate my concerns
i believe that cutting swept simply
shifts the burden
into local property taxes in those towns
and cities that can least afford it
in addition it does nothing to um look
at the enrollment numbers and the
difficulties that school districts have
i would fervently ask you to vote no
on this amendment so that we can come
back with another amendment
based on our previous conversation thank
you madam chair
representative lynn yeah i uh
thank you madam chair i just want to
make sure so
what this would do would reduce the
education
property tax and make up for that money
from the general fund is that correct
that's correct okay hey thank you very
much
yeah we're not we're not taking any
money out of
sweat or just replacing
the reduction in taxes across the state
for the
property tax payers
representative murray so is this
just for this year or this i guess this
biennium
um so presumably in the next biennium
the swept would go back to where it is
now
okay let me just say this swept
in 23 will be
we will collect from the taxpayers
the 263.
we will replace the 100 million
uh that isn't there with general funds
money
so there's no change in how much
money will be uh provided by
swep to fund adequate education
that number of 363 stays there
it's just the method of how we
pay for it right follow-up certainly
so presumably because
we're putting 100 million into this fund
people would likely expect that their
so when we come to the point where we
don't put in the 100 million again
then we might expect the swept fund the
swept
rate to go back up to what it was in
order to
generate the 363. so this is
um an event for this biennium but it's
not necessarily an event going forward
it's that's that's correct
that's correct it's a one it's one off
it's a one time
thank you right and that would be the
same thing
with um representative he's
amendment that it would be a
one-off because we don't
well who knows but we can't
we can't promise the future as you know
um i wish i could but we can't
and uh and that's um that's one of my
major concerns with uh representative
heath's amendment
is that we are setting people up
trying thinking that we are shorting
them in the future
representative heath with that said
madam chair
i i really ask the
members of the committee to think about
number one
for local school districts trying to
establish their budget
this would mean they would know how much
money would be forthcoming
it would be a bigger
advantage to those school districts
across
our state that are struggling
with coming up with significant dollars
to in fact pay their local property
taxes
and it just it it doesn't do for our
schools
what we need to have done we don't
change the numbers
we don't address the enrollment numbers
um so i again i would ask
the committee to vote no on this
amendment
so that we can come back this afternoon
with another amendment
that uses the hundred million dollars to
really address
fully and i believe in a better way
again swept will
impact some of the most wealthy towns
people are used to paying
the prop the statewide property taxes we
end up
hurting those districts that lease can
afford it
amendment
um i could some is it uh representative
murray are you
have your hand raised um yes i do um i
i don't know if i was before
representative lin or not but i can be
quick
um as we did a reconsideration on a
previous amendment
regardless of how this goes if it's up
or down is it still possible to bring
in the sort of amendment that we were
discussing
this afternoon regardless of how this
goes could we still bring in the other
amendment for consideration
for consideration and then seeing how
that goes have reconsideration on this
one
okay um uh andrea could you take this
down
because my computer doesn't show me
who's uh
wants to talk and i think we all know
what this says
so if you don't mind oh absolutely
okay uh representative lynn you have
your hand raised
yes i uh thank you so i just want to
make sure that
i'm understanding um in light of what
representative heath
had said if if we
approve this amendment
it does not result in any lower funding
of monies going for education
it simply means that instead of the
money
coming from the statewide education
property tax it will come
from other state revenue sources
which does not include the statewide
education property tax
so that to the extent that most of that
of those other sources involve monies
from the business profits tax or the
business enterprise tax
it will mean that uh to quote some of
the people
that i've heard talk about this it will
mean that out of state big out-of-state
corporations
are paying more um
paying a bigger share of the cost of
education than the property taxpayers
are um unless i'm missing something that
seems to me to
um seems to me to be um what
uh what we're talking about and so i
guess i'm
i don't i don't think i have a problem
mickey would you like to uh provide some
sort of
um
i don't think i can really get into a
whole lot of detail or thoughts on that
but to the extent that
less of the pool of money for
funding education trust fund
expenditures comes from
directly from property tax receipts
i think his point is is on the right
track
okay thank you okay
all right um i will agree
and i hope that everyone will nod their
head yes
that we will vote on one zero
one eight but we will
also allow
representative heath and whoever
to bring in an amendment this afternoon
that we can discuss and
if that one passes then we would
reconsider
is there anybody okay
representative just to be clear so i
know what i'm voting on
so if i were to vote yes on this
amendment
we'll have time to work with mickey
to come back this afternoon
well whenever whenever you're whenever
it's ready
uh to in fact amend this bill
and change the purpose of the hundred
million dollars that you are talking
about that's
thank you ma'am cheer i mean if you know
if it wasn't thursday after thursday
morning
that could be something that you would
do anyhow
and so since it's thursday morning
i uh i recognize that
we need to follow the same sort of
protocol that we have
you have another question um so
if we vote right now um chances are that
as a division
we're not going to be able to come back
so would this be an amendment
that um i would bring forward to the
full finance committee
no we can bring it back here we can
bring it back here
okay thank you thank you madam chair
yeah we just have to uh
figure out a time and that's
uh that's going to be you know it may be
it may be best just to do it tomorrow
morning at 10 o'clock
because we have our we have our schedule
i think
set that we were going to um
be here at 10 o'clock tomorrow morning
so
yes go ahead okay um so
what i think that i'm going to vote yes
on
is that i would agree to the 100 million
dollars
with the understanding that we will work
with mickey
and come up with an amendment to this
for reconsideration of this amendment
um at some point before it goes to full
finance
yes am i correct yes you are correct
okay is um is this afternoon an option
representative omburger because we could
probably turn this around pretty quick
if you did want to finish business today
well let me let me see how many people
are available this
is everyone available at
am i seeing yeses from everybody
okay so um
let me just look at my schedule i i
the one day i only have one meeting okay
so uh mickey what do you think's the
i think two o'clock might be a a good
target we could try to
turn something around for that um i i
have faith ols will be able to turn
something around quick for us
okay and if we don't um
i want to know who the stand-up comic is
we can use our time wisely until
until ols gets the
the thing back or do i need to hire
somebody to come in
for that okay represent heath
thank you madam chair and and i i just
um
employ the committee to look at the
handout
that um uh that mickey sent to you
showing the difference in towns and
communities
even based on a pro-rated uh basic
basis um there is a lot more money that
will be going in
to what school districts will be
receiving
so i really ask for that consideration
this afternoon
okay we'll vote yes on this bill
on this amendment all right thank you
very much um
so are i don't think i have a motion do
i
um one zero one eight or do well
not yet okay representative petrie made
second okay thank you
would you please call the role yes
certainly um uh representative petry
representative petri vocias
representative bucca
yes uh representative heath
keith votes yes trusting my chair
representative murder representative
uh representative lynn votes yes uh
representative murray
murray votes yes and representative
humber
representative umberger votes yes all
right
it's a vote of seven to zero in the
affirmative uh matter
okay and uh we all understand that
uh will oh
mickey is there well we will have to
wait till two o'clock right to vote on
the other things that we need to vote on
um i mean it's really a
formality if you want to just make it
clear that you're done with your work
once you're done
done everything we can do a final vote
saying you know
uh house bill 1 and 2 are closed out
with the amendments that we've already
previously adopted to this point so
perhaps we can save that for the end of
the back end of today
okay yeah and um and we also need to
give you authority to true up things or
whatever
yeah whatever yeah we usually get that
officially with the full committee but
if you want to just make it clear you
trust me to make sure i carry out the
division's work that's fine too
that works too if we don't trust you
we're in trouble
exactly here yeah yeah is there anything
else
at this point we need to let them get to
work
so um i'll see you all
at uh two o'clock thank you very much